hey everybody its Jesse and in this
stream you all can watch me would do my
day-to-day work I'm just a front-end
developer to university and this is not
scripted at all and so I'll make
mistakes and try to work through them
and hopefully we can help each other and
and learn together so today we're gonna
continue with what we were doing
yesterday and that is trying to turn
this header into something that looks
like this so today I think we'll we'll
just work on this header portion we'll
save the side nav for another day
because I don't think we'll get through
it all in one stream the main site that
the main goal is to make this site run
more quickly so we'll load it up here
not bad that was a little bit faster
than usual the internet connection is
good here and this site is hosted on
campus so shouldn't be too much of a
round trip but you can see the current
site this is gonna change significantly
we went over a lot of the changes in
yesterday stream so if you missed that
you could check that out probably and
it'll be in the first half of that
stream so this is a copy of that page
with most of the stuff removed so I
haven't done that much since yesterday
let me show you what I did do
so yesterday one of the last things we
did was make a test version of this main
nav component and we had it connected to
the main nav
dot cs5 whoops and I just noticed I put
two dots in there so let's let's rename
that now before before it messes
something up sorry about that my phone's
ringing I don't recognize the number so
I'm just gonna let it go okay so now
that has the correct name and what we've
done is we've brought imported this in
here as maintenance so the reason I did
that is because I was looking through
this a little bit and there were some
areas where I thought we may want to
change the mark up like for instance you
know we do have some you know some HTML
you know that we may want to change so I
figured you know I may as well make a
test page you know first if if you
weren't watching yesterday an important
thing to know about this project is that
this file structure that you just saw a
second ago here these are the live files
for the site so there is no test site
there's there is something that they
call a test site but it shares all the
same files so I'm not really sure what
what about it is a test site I think
maybe it has a different database but so
that's why we have to make copies test
copies of all these files before we make
anything go alive all right so let me
check out the live chat just say hello
to everyone before we get started
hey everybody
alright so the way I divide up things in
this stream is with a Pomodoro timer so
I'm gonna start this and we're gonna do
25 minutes of coding and then I'll do
five minutes of answering questions in
the live chat and I'll check back in
periodically during the coding into live
chat especially if I need some help or
you know if I if I get to a point where
I think someone might have something to
say then I'll check back over there but
otherwise if you ask a question during
that 25-minute period just hang in there
and I'll do my best to get to it during
the five minutes after we do probably
about two Pomodoro sessions then I'll
take the end of the stream and answer
any questions that are left over that I
didn't get to so if you could stick
around to the end your question will be
answered eventually and if you can't
stick around to the end go ahead and ask
it anyway and then you can catch the
recording later on it's also not a bad
idea just ask a question whenever I am
coding and there are a lot of people in
the live chat that are so knowledgeable
more knowledgeable than me and on a lot
of things and they can help you out as
well okay so let's get started I think I
saw some new some new names I haven't
seen before in the live chat so if
you're new welcome thank you so much for
for joining joining in the live chat and
for watching alright let's get started
well one thing that we're definitely
going to have to do is change the
structure of this of this navbar I mean
this is the HTML was significantly
different so that's what we'll work on
first I'm also using materialize the
materialized CSS framework to do this so
we're gonna bring that in I'm so I'm
hesitant to bring in another framework
on a site that's already really slow but
we're already loading jQuery so we're
not adding anything by using a framework
that's going to need jQuery as well and
we can't get rid of it there's just too
much on the site already that's using it
so since we already have jQuery I think
it'll be all right
what we'll probably end up doing is
after we get everything looking how we
want we can go through the materialized
JavaScript and CSS and remove anything
that we're not using and get those file
sizes down you know as small as we can
but I think the benefit of being able to
use a lot of the things that are built
in to to materialize is is do not
outweigh our you know any you know
slight increase I think you know in load
times you know it'll be it'll be minimal
okay this is also officially project
three now in the video so in the titles
of the videos I'll I'll put in
parentheses at the end of each title
it'll be p3 for project three and then
I'll put D this is day two so it's D two
that way it'll be a little bit easier to
keep up I'll probably make a playlist
once I get a few more videos I'll make a
playlist specifically for this project
this project we may have to work on a
little bit and then do some other stuff
and then maybe come back to it you know
this is a really large site it's going
to be an ongoing project I'm gonna move
this over to my other screen and I'm
also gonna move this over because dev
tools is probably going to be more
useful at this point and also my
my editors so at first
let me grab let me get Adam also I
finally figured out four on project two
I figured out how to position that I
that checkbox icon so if anybody's
interested in how I did that just ask it
in the live chat and I'll get to it
during one of the question
question-and-answer sessions so it
actually it took me three times as long
as I estimated that it would take it was
quite frustrating but I finally got it
to the point where it it works and it
looks the way I wanted to look okay so
here's the Trello board for this project
a lot of stuff going on here I'm not
sure if I even have one for the header
right now I'm not gonna worry about this
now the reason I scrolled over was to
get to this so this is the the project
that you just saw the the goal header
right how we want it to look so I want
to grab the mark-up for that that nav
from here bring it over and then we'll
go from there and trying to plug in the
data from the content management system
and the the CMS that we're using is
called Ektron it's it's pretty old so
we'll see how it works we're just gonna
have to learn it as we you know how
things are put together as we go along
alright
that's the side now we're not gonna mess
with the side nav right now okay
so I think this should be it if we just
grab this nav element and we can double
check mmm
actually we're gonna need we need this
div as well we need to grab the entire
header let's bring over the entire
header we're gonna need to do it at some
point anyway so you may as well do it
now like I said we're not really gonna
work on the side nav for now mm-hmm
that's interesting I think I can safely
take that out everything's working it's
been commented out for a while
okay
I was just thinking we could potentially
split this up into two different
components but I I think it'll be easier
to start out with just to put it all in
the main nav component and then if we we
feel like it's too much at some point we
can always split it out at that point
okay so now that we have that we
shouldn't really need to come back to
this except maybe to grab maybe some
some of the materialized code I want to
see where I'm loading this if I'm using
a CDN or not okay so I am importing the
JavaScript from a CDN but I want to get
the latest version so we can just go on
materialized and figure out where the
latest versions are okay so let's go I'm
gonna leave this in for now and we're
just gonna have to edit this to make it
work with with our search bugs all right
I think
hmm
alright all of this is commented out I'm
gonna get rid of this because we can
always refer to it in the version the
non-test version of this in case there's
something that something in here that
would be useful to us but for now I'm
just gonna get rid of all of this yeah
we're just gonna get rid of the nav I
guess we can't I want to keep some of
this down here so this this template so
everything inside this repeater I do
want to keep for now just to reference
it but all of this can go let me know if
the font size is big enough area okay so
that's everything and I should be able
to paste the the indentation on this is
not great let's bring it back a bit
so I'm using Visual Studio code for this
which I don't normally use so it's
that's a little bit of a different feel
to it so I'm still kind of getting used
to that all right let's see all right so
let's paste this in now and so we do
have some of the header and the nav so
we can get rid of we can get rid of this
nav and I guess this ul
I guess Oh worry about indentation later
I'm gonna take that out it's comment it
out so probably don't need it and that's
where it's it was closed we'll take that
out as well and here's our huge side nav
okay this is what I wanted so now we got
down to here
[Music]
let's take take these two out since we
deleted deleted them up there these are
just closing text what will be deleted
and let's grab you know what let's
remove this and we'll just pull up the
other version of this the live version
and then we can put it over here and and
just look look on refer to it on that
side so let me bring this
okay
alright let me scroll down good so this
is what we we want to bring in this
repeater and then there's a template for
our for our links in here so we kind of
just want to break this down try to
figure out what's going on and what data
is being imported hopefully the names
are gonna be descriptive enough that
we'll be able to tell what's you know
what's going on we may have to just kind
of look around a bit and refer to the
site and and figure it out but we should
have all the data that we need you know
just from these from this template
basically to populate our new nav so the
the social media I think I mentioned
this yesterday all the social media
links we're just going to keep them as
is and we'll just hard code the URLs I
think right now there's yeah I don't
even have URLs in there right now so we
will hard code those in there and I'm
okay with that let's see what we really
want we really need to worry about
pulling in dynamically or these links
the donate button can be hard coded and
probably these ones these ones can be
are coded this about academics
admissions faith life those are not
likely to change it's more these she's
interior links actually these aren't
likely to change it may be a lot easier
than I thought to put in the new header
will be the tricky part as the side now
so we may actually get get to the side
enough we'll see we'll see how tough it
is to get this header working
you know we still still haven't even
tested it we do need to hook up this
search input so we need to see how it's
working here and try to pull in all the
same values and see if it can work here
as well so actually bringing in this
text box search
I'm checking the I'm just shade a live
chat briefly okay I think this is
probably we're gonna have to find this
because I want to make sure
that's interesting I must have I must
have opened up the site in dev tools and
pulled in the names from into there
which was okay and would normally work
but I'd rather pull it in here since we
can get these values kind of more
directly so let's try to find this
textbox let's see let me get out of mode
so I can get it to here so what was that
called again
it was the text text box let's see if we
can find it
okay this is some of the search stuff
but not not the text box
okay I was hoping it was in there but I
don't think it is so let's see where
else
hmm
I want to check out what gets what the
output of this is if it's just simply an
input then we don't really need to know
anything else so and that'll be fine
is we'll just put in these these values
so let's look at the site in dev tools
then alright so this is the inputs let
me make sure whoops
alright so it is this day of his header
search so within that div yes all we
have is just the input great alright
then we don't really need to find out
where this textbox is coming from let's
just plug in these values that we need
so probably the easiest thing will be to
just copy this whole thing and paste it
in there and we'll make sure we add the
right class names for our styles to work
so we want the placeholder I guess it
can be can be searched with the dots
that's fine name search type search
class okay that looks good I actually
don't really have any any other class
name so this will be perfect okay great
and that should be it the search should
work now you can see there's nothing
else you know being pulled in here this
is just plain HTML the same way with
this this icon here so all this should
be fine
great now while we're doing this we
should probably put it in the side nav
as well since I'm I have a search input
in the side nav so let me double check
to see if I have anything different
going on I don't think so
so let's put that in there as well all
right now that's ready and those should
work we could actually I wonder what
this looks like now that we've been kind
of messing around with it
put it up pull with put this on another
screen okay we're definitely getting
some errors here let me pull this over
to show you the areas that we're getting
I do want to double check and make sure
that none of those errors are are
bleeding over into the main site okay
good it still loads the site's really
buggy so sometimes I'll change something
that seems like it should be fine and
not affect anything I mean just
extremely simple things will be changed
and large portions of the site will just
go down and display something like this
so I want to be really careful about you
know double-checking this is our main
website it you know it gets a lot of
traffic you know in the millions of
visits there going on a yearly basis you
know millions so it's by far the most
visited of all the sites that that I
work on here for the University so you
know realistically if that if I
accidentally took the site down
potentially we could lose money from
donors and from potential students so
it's worth the caution all right so
let's see an error occurred it's already
used by another control
oh okay maybe we are gonna have a
problem since we have things with the
same ID yeah it could be a problem what
ID did we have before let me check this
yes folks
we're gonna have to think think about
what we want to do then for the search
actually let's let's check this out
right now I think there is a like a
mobile search so I'm interested to see
what what happens there
so let's shrink this down and click
search and let's see if it's the same
input or what's going on there
is there an ID I'm not seeing an idea at
all okay so it's mobile search box
mobile search placeholder search
I tell you what I'm gonna do what I
think might be the simplest thing just
to test this out would be just to change
the ID and yeah we'll just change the ID
and see what happens and see if we can
get it to work we should be able to
check
yeah if what we could possibly do is
just have to two functions here and this
is in I believe c-sharp I don't have
very much experience at all the C sharp
so if I'm messing up any terminology I
apologize and please let me know what
[Music]
with the the right way to talk about
this stuff is all right so let me search
clear
okay I'm just checking to see if these
exist somewhere else in in the same file
I'm just not sure how how these link up
where did this come from that's just
okay so that's just hanging out at the
end here
interesting
hmm yeah I'm not exactly sure how rights
to the on click that's firing off this
function its button search click the on
click handler is down here on this
button with the class button search but
this is what's actually visible to the
user so I'm just trying to figure out
how these are linked up interesting
let me
I want to check to see if there's okay
okay here this is that button and we can
see it's not
there's there's nothing it's um
it's not visible
hmm
you know what I bet the answer's up here
I had forgotten that there was some code
up at the top some JavaScript so we'll
see okay so they're grabbing the
textbook search so this key press 13 I
think is enter so if they're gonna hit
enter then it's going to okay then it's
gonna just click using jQuery it's going
to click the button search alright
interesting so they have a hidden submit
button and they're just using jQuery to
make that button get clicked that works
I definitely I don't think I would do it
that way but I'm not upset about it
because I understand what's going on so
so that's good where's
actually this is interesting too they
have this commented out where's this
function
it looks like they changed it okay my
timer went off so I'm gonna do my five
minutes of a question answer in just a
second but I just wanted to see if you
all see this it's really interesting let
me switch this to JavaScript for a
minute we get some highlighting here we
go and that'll be a lot easier actually
this is not bad let's see how that's I
might just leave it as JavaScript
highlighting because that looks pretty
good so if you check this out so our
button search click it's at one point it
seems like maybe this was the way they
had set it up and then they changed
their minds which which makes sense like
I said this is not the way I would have
done it but they changed their minds and
they grabbed the value and then run this
function to do the search and it's
actually changing the URL of the page
and then just adding the search value as
a query string right at the end of the
URL so that's how they decided to do the
search so really we can get rid of we
can get rid of all this stuff that's not
in use
and just kind of make this smaller clean
it up we can also get rid of that button
and now that we know how this works it
really doesn't matter much what we're
going to do with that mobile search
because the search essentially is just
it seems like it's all taken care of
here I want to double check all right
when we come back from the five minute
break for questions the first thing I
want to do is well I want to remove this
button
our test file but then also in our CS
file I really I want to look at this and
try to figure out what's going on and if
this is even being called at all because
I think the answer is no I think that
this is not even in use so that we could
also remove this and yeah we could
remove this or potentially we could get
rid of a lot of this jQuery and then
make use of this I'm not sure what the
best one is but let me know anybody
especially that knows more about you
know kind of dotnet stuff than I do
which is probably anybody that knows
anything about death let me know what do
you think the best way to do this would
be it may not matter what is it better
to use jQuery to change the location and
we could refactor this and not use
jQuery if we really wanted to but I
think we're gonna we're gonna need it
for other places on the site so I don't
think it would be useful to get rid of
it or is it better to do it like this
yeah look let me know what you think so
let me start boobs I'm gonna start my
five-minute timer I'm gonna do
whoops sorry my camera first I just just
now saw that yeah so if you remember if
you're watching yesterday you know my
camera kept freezing and I had to just
restart it this is just the built-in
camera on my iMac monitor so um I don't
know what to do about it we'll see if it
keeps doing this and it's a problem all
I might just get another camera alright
so I'm just going up to the top of the
live chat I'm gonna run through and just
try to find the questions and get as
many as I can in Abdullah Abdullah not
exactly sure how you pronounce the end
of that so sorry
that says what's the best laptop for
coding yeah it depends on what operating
system you like to use which is so smoke
one says also mentions that depends on
your operating system I really like a my
macbook pro I think it's great to work
on it starts up it's fast it has good
battery life I've been less than
impressed with a lot of the Windows
laptops that I've had before but I don't
think it's a fair comparison because
I've never bought a Windows laptop that
would that was as expensive as a macbook
pro so if I were to buy a Windows laptop
that was that expensive maybe it would
be as good or better I'm not sure i've
never used Linux on a laptop so I don't
know but my next laptop purchase you
know for my own personal use is probably
going to be Linux I'd really like to try
it out but I do have a MacBook I think
it's like a 15-inch MacBook Pro and it
was the last model that still had the
the HDMI connection and that's been
really useful for me because so many
things hook up through HDMI so I really
like that I don't remember what year
that is maybe 2015 or something like
that so the newer models have that that
touch bar thing which that's pretty cool
too
but I think everything's done through
USB see connectors so for right now it's
somewhat of a problem because you know a
lot of your older things don't don't use
the USB see so you need a lot of
adapters then anyway that's my as my
thoughts on it not really technical but
those are just some of my observations
no Bo says Jessie can you give us the
code that you have local on localhost
yeah
so let's see I figure you're probably
talking about was that I've lost that
that here you know anyway I'm pretty
sure you were talking about that example
site that we were that I was showing and
I do have that code available so let me
find the repo for you so I remember what
the name of it is
okay so here's the repository so I
haven't done this is just the initial I
just wanted to put this on github so you
all have it so here it is I am I
definitely wanna update materialized
because this is using an older version
so I want to update that that'll
probably one of the first things I do to
change this and then we're also going to
be developing a lot of the UI elements
here because we can make use of my local
development environment will develop it
here and then transfer it over into the
test versions the test files that we
have for the actual site and plug in the
values that we need you know into the
templates so we'll basically convert
these into templates that will work on
the site but it's going to be a lot
faster to get them to look how we want
them to look here locally and then move
them over so that'll kind of be the the
workflow we'll just switch over and try
to go you know one component at a time
but I will put this in the live chat and
actually I just saw Umberto has a bunch
of comments so I'm assuming I did
something wrong usually when I see a lot
of comments like that it means I did did
something wrong so let me see all the
web forms suggestions
okay so let me let me read a little bit
of what Umberto said because it's
definitely it it's useful and it
pertains to you know a lot so if you
don't know from being in the live chat
Umberto he knows about c-sharp and he's
actually doing his own YouTube videos so
about that which I may be watching those
I want to watch them anyway but now I
may really want to be watching them so
that I can can know how about having to
work on this project
alright so let me read out what he said
so he said basically said you might
really want to create a separate folder
with its own web config and remove the
custom errors from the main web config
when you add an SP control and give it
an ID that ID is available as an object
in the code behind ASP uses a feature
where you can make a handler by using
the ID underscore handle events
signature and the code behind so awesome
so that definitely explains a lot of
what I was trying to guess at so sorry
about that I should have looked over and
saw that that would have saved me a lot
of time so yes that's a basically what's
what's going on here then is we can let
me read this I get it right to explain
this you all give it a 90 days
it's an object alright so yeah so we can
have the ID which was okay so we have
button search right click so on button
search click then it's gonna it's gonna
run this right so and you can get the
event so that's what's going on here
that's how they they were connected up
oops there we go sorry that's it okay
yeah now I remember
so we did end up figuring that out at
some point because we have this on click
of button search click right but we can
also get right so this was the ID I'm
not gonna scroll but I'm pretty sure
that was the ID so Umberto was saying
that the the ID is available as an
object in the code behind so that's what
we can get this txb search dot text so I
wasn't sure how that exactly that was
available but that's evidently yet
that's normal for ASP so I just paid you
okay cool that makes more sense now
thank you Umberto let me
right down where I left off at in the
live chat so I can go back to it
actually we just had a I had another
someone had another question about the
the link for sorry I'm trying to type
and talk at the same time there was one
other question about the link to the
very first video where I talked about
this which was I actually had done
months ago on my channel so I'm gonna
put that link in the live chat right now
and I'll have to remember to put that
into the description of the video or
something but that link that I just
posted in a live chat that will take you
to the video on on my own channel where
I introduce this website and I talked I
kind of go through it in a lot more
detail than I did yesterday and
explaining what's wrong with it and what
needs to be done alright so now let's
get started with our other session so
this will be our last session of coding
and I'm bare so I'm I'm not gonna make
the umberto recommended making a
separate folder with its own web config
I'm not going to do that right now
because I think that'll be involved and
I'll make a lot of mistakes and I don't
so I don't have time for that so it will
either be maybe for tomorrow stream or
I'll try to do it before the before
tomorrow stream
okay so what we're gonna do so I I think
we can so I think we can get rid of this
oh okay we were going to we were going
to see if we wanted to use this and I
what I think now let me see if anyone
else had any opinions on that
okay so I don't think anyone had any
opinions one way or the other but I'm
thinking I'm Way more familiar with
JavaScript and jQuery than I am with
c-sharp so I'm gonna take this out and
I'm gonna continue to use the the jQuery
I'm just gonna I'm double checking here
just to make sure yeah I don't think
this is let me know especially Umberto I
don't think that this is doing anything
here other than basically it was doing
the same thing that this jQuery was
doing it was just changing the URL so
I'll remove that we we have the the
other copy of it so if I end up removing
something and it really messes things up
it will be fine
just trying to see if we had that I
should have done this now I already
checked beforehand whether any you know
the name of that anything in there was
was elsewhere so I think we're good and
now that I already removed this now I
can remove this as well great I love
when I get to remove lots of code I
guess that wasn't a lot of code but
still it feels good all right now what
we need to do is give this a different
ID so
Seiden have so we're just gonna add side
and have onto the end of that and then
up here we're gonna make sure that we
actually we're already looking at the
text boxers
- time suits
all right I think this will work right
so we were getting an error because we
had two text box components with the
same ID so we changed the ID but the
jQuery was actually trying to get the
class and it looks like everything's
still going to work properly even if
they have the same class which is great
at first I thought if they were using
IDs I would have to duplicate this which
which wouldn't be great also we're not
gonna we're not going to have a mobile
search box so we can remove this and
image search I think this is yeah this
is a click on the icon which we don't
have that icon anymore but let's make
sure let me scroll down to our to our
text box here and search icon so we're
using the class search icon for to make
sure we're doing it for both no actually
we're not let's add the class
actually I'm not sure we may have styles
attached to that so I don't want to just
add the search class search input well
we're not using
I guess we do have a search icon up here
Oh what is this for
I got a double check and see what I did
with this with this navbar and I can't
it's not this I'll just bring it up like
three thousand and is it one yeah that's
it all right let me see what I was
telling here oh okay that's why I
couldn't figure out why I had to SVG's
it's the the clothes so I have I have
the wrong SVG class Image Search okay
great so I've already given this the
right class of this image search so
let's just make sure we use the same oh
we are using the same class all right so
we're already good so I had already
taken care of that and I'd done this
months ago so that's why I did not
remember at all so that should still
work so if you see we're already looking
for that that class and then we have a
click handler on that class to do the
search based on that value so if enter
is pressed so this this e which equals
13 that that bothers me that it's only 2
equals I'm gonna I'm gonna fix that so
anyway this this will work to do a
search so enter will work a click on the
search icon will also work and then
search button we're not gonna have a
separate search button so we can remove
that as well we'll keep this here this
check and we'll also keep this and so
this should all work that we managed to
remove a good bit of it and it should
still work so let's test it out
still getting oh I got a refresh I'm so
used to the the auto refresh when I'm
working locally that I keep forgetting
let's see repeater outer Davis and once
again I do want to keep refreshing this
just to make sure okay great
okay so let's see what line we're on
Main Ave test like 33 okay so let's
check line 30 whoops yeah
I'm 33
okay maybe I just my my first thought on
this error is that since the IDS of
things are passed automatically here is
that something that I deleted the ID was
being passed in and used somewhere in
here and now that's why I'm getting the
error so I guess I'll go through quickly
and check this out
scroll
see
I don't think I've seen anything let me
check the live chat see if you all have
seen anything
okay so Umberto's saying taxonomy data
looks like a custom class and taxonomy
manager okay all right so you're using
taxonomy data
it's okay repeater outer side we did see
this right repeater potatoes let's see
all the places where this is just just
to see if this maybe has something to do
with anything
okay
alright here's here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna check some of the things the
classes of some of the things that I
deleted and I'm sorry the IDS just to be
sure
alright no results and we didn't remove
that hmm what did remove I don't know
that we really removed anything to
remove now we kept that it's double
check
where is it
did I get rid of this repeater
completely I thought I left it in and
maybe I didn't
okay I think that I think that's the
reason so it's looking for for this and
it doesn't it's not finding it so let's
grab
let's grab this and we'll just put it in
here somewhere
so we're probably gonna end up using
this in the side nav but for now I'm
just gonna throw it in here so that we
quit getting the air I just want to test
the check pucks or the the search box
just to make sure it actually does work
so let's see all right let me have
okay all right so Umberto's says no
space is that a bit yeah
no space after the : okay I don't know
how a space got in there that's crazy
look at that
how did that happen so there was no
space in there and then when I pasted it
there was a space really weird okay
let's
what the heck Oh more spaces let's make
sure
okay
let's see
all right cool I can't see the search
bar is that okay that makes sense cuz I
didn't bring in let's say let's see what
the would actually get pulled in
the heck is all that okay all right
okay
okay thinking maybe it's yeah there we
go yeah
mmm
now where's when
let me see what mark up I even have in
here okay with the header
let's go to our main file and see I mean
the master let's see where we're pulling
that in it Wow what should I see let's
see the dead does
actually I don't really like how that
looks let's let's do it as try HTML
that's better okay so my main content so
our nav here we go okay our main nav
should be in between the utility nav and
the utility nav mobile all right
actually we don't even want that mobile
nav anymore
we're just gonna have one nav so let's
get rid of that let's get rid of that
and I'm not sure what that utility nav
is I'll leave it in for now but I think
we'll probably be able to get rid of
that as well I don't want this see
there's a lot of this markup here menu
buttons yeah we don't need this mobile
search box text box oh yeah we don't
need a lot of this yes if any
yeah let me get rid of a lot of this
since we don't need it
you don't need that and yeah we don't
need this and we actually we don't even
need the header class yeah I think this
is probably gonna cause errors but I
don't need any of this stuff and then
you container I'm getting rid of this -
all right section gone go book on
section yeah get rid of all of that
there we go
get rid of that and get rid of some of
these spaces okay all right so you've
got basically what we've done is there
was a lot of markup here that is
actually taken care of inside of this
main nav component now so yeah main nav
oh you know what we actually changed the
name so that's probably a big reason why
why this didn't work that would make
sense so I think initially it was main
that one and then I changed it to test
and I never changed it in here
so I may have made enough test tag name
a nav okay I left it as made enough and
for some reason it's saying may not one
so let's put the right name in here if I
can find it
there you go
well actually it doesn't matter now that
this is the this is what matters
okay
so may have and I want to remove the
things that we took out of here so that
utility now is gone and utility that
mobile is gone some of this other stuff
is gonna go as well but we'll wait till
we get to that point
alright let's save that and see what
kind of errors we're gonna get all right
constant blows out to full okay
all right so we're gonna need to get rid
of some stuff here in our main test
master CS file so let's check that out
now
all right so where we at line 40 so in
line 40 we can get rid of this top
header because we totally remove that
okay and let's see yeah I'm not worried
about that a lot of these these sections
are so that they you can control what's
in the header through the CMS but I
don't need their the parts of the header
that need to be controlled will be
controlled but that's mainly just gonna
be the links and that's only gonna be in
the side nav so it's better just to take
it out and let's see if anything else
everything else seems like it's dealing
with a footer
okay all right let's try that I'm really
surprised that how how easy it is to
catch on to what's what's happening so
like I said I've pretty much never used
c-sharp before or anything dotnet other
than me kind of messing around with it a
few months ago but it's well you know
they say the programming concepts the
concepts remain the same it's just
syntax that's that's different
alright so I still don't see the search
bar but I would like to check out what's
going on over here page outer wrapper
actually not sure why we're still
getting that
yeah I don't think we should be getting
that bad menu
okay so here is our
interesting
okay so basically we are getting the
correct output on the on the screen it's
just seems like there's some styles that
are either conflicting or just not
working because we didn't pull in any of
the wow it's just oh it's probably just
something simple that I could find in
dev tools okay this is the on mobile
stuff
okay yeah we don't obviously since we
don't have the media queries that are
supposed to govern this probably what's
happening is so the the desktop menu
must be hidden somewhere I just can't
find I can't find where it's being
hidden I guess it would just be there we
go show on large
now actually now that I think about it
none of the classes will work so I'm not
sure I'm not worried about it it's
showing up here that's just a matter of
bringing in the right styles but you can
see we are actually getting what we want
the main thing that I'm worried about
here is checking to see that we we can
get that search that search bar so we're
let's
see where it should be
okay so if I search input
okay if you look for search input great
all right so we do have an input here
and it looks like I mean it looks good
this looks like it has what it should
let's see if we can bring this out
somehow
to play blog fixed I would say find it
no no it's still down there
yes
okay all right so for whatever reason I
can't see anything so let's go over my
timer turned off so I'm gonna do well I
guess that's it so we're just going to
do two Pomodoro sessions today and I
have an appointment in a little while
and it's gonna take me probably a half
hour or so to drive there so I got to
make sure whoops my my camera's off
again sorry about that
so anyway I gotta make sure I'm not late
for that that's why I extreme dab it
earlier than normal today okay I'm gonna
scroll back up to where I was before and
answer as many questions as I can I
should be able to get to them all it
doesn't look like there's too many if
you if you can't stick around for the
question answer session thank you so
much for watching I'll probably be back
tomorrow
around 2:00 did it freeze again already
never unfroze I forgot to put in my
password I keep running I keep running
this command
it's a pseudo kill-all VDC assistant
every time it freezes and that makes it
unfreeze temporarily so anyway let me
yeah let me get to the questions if you
have a question go ahead and put it in a
live chat now and I should be able to
get to it here in a few minutes okay
okay no beer says I can't install Visual
Studio code editor I'm using Windows 8.1
I tried several times to install it but
it comes up with an error help me please
man I'm not sure I don't I don't have
any machines that are running a Windows
8.1 so I've never had anything running
it so I'm really kind of at a loss for
how how to do things on there but
hopefully there's somebody else here in
the live chat that has some experience
with it all right
see
okay Alberto says the bad thing about
asp.net is that it uses a lot of post
backs of page refreshes at least reforms
yes I've noticed that every time I do
have to do anything with dotnet the
whole thing's in a form so I don't know
if you notice this but I mean check this
out
or that so the whole thing is in a form
right so let's look at that that's all
of our content basically in this form
it's just weird what why is it all in a
form and then it messes it up so trying
to do things within this form like forms
within a form it I've always had trouble
with this so yeah and the page refreshes
are terrible so I much prefer you know
sending form data with fetch or with
Ajax you know xhr and not having a
refresh anyway I'm sure maybe if I knew
more about it I it wouldn't be such a
big deal and that is probably some way
to work with it
Harshit says where is this site hosted
okay it's it is hosted here on campus in
the in a different building that I'm at
but probably I don't know less than two
hundred yards from me is the server that
that hosts this website so it's actually
hosted on servers here but hopefully
that will change when we redo the site
so when we rebuild it will probably
rebuild it with react and I don't know
what we use for content management
maybe WordPress maybe if we can find
something else I'd kind of prefer to
have something you know nodejs based
just to keep the whole stack JavaScript
I'm like somewhat thinking about just
making my own really lightweight CMS I
think that would be cool but we'll see
so anyway at that point it'll be hosted
elsewhere so maybe I don't know maybe
digitalocean AWS I'm really not decided
yet as to where it'll be hosted but
it'll be something like that
okay I'm buried so I see now that you
asked if I deleted the repeater yeah
that's it and that was in fact the
problem so sometimes I just I don't look
over fast enough to the live chat but I
you're pointing out what I'm what I'm
missing even though I don't always get
to it right away
oh wow I'm there's embarrassing even
gave me the line then the number is line
152 thank you so much again I'm sorry
that I didn't see it
Nicholas asked is the react to the react
project to complete its almost complete
I worked on just some some little stuff
some positioning like UI positioning at
UI elements and things the only the only
major thing left to do is handle the
kind of clean up the email templates a
little bit so that an email gets sent to
the user who submits a form and it also
gets sent to our project manager and
making sure that those emails look
alright that's about it also you know
possibly just some some testing in
different devices and things like that
but there's really not anything
significant that I could do a stream
about that I think would be really
interesting so that's why I switched
over to this so I'll be doing handling
those last few things you know kind of
earlier in the day and then I'll be
doing this for the stream and I still
need to get some feedback from people in
my department about project two to see
what they think
see if there's any changes needed it's
possible if something comes up that I
think would be good to do the stream
about then I might go back and you know
we'll switch it up and go back to
project two and then you know kind of go
back and forth and then it'll be you
know in the title of the videos it'll
it'll say what project it is but
basically you know at this point I
consider it for the most part done you
know I think it could be in in less than
a day I think it could be in shape to
where you'd be completely ready ready to
go
all right so Berto says so this ASP
control takes a data source the results
from a query for example as data set
okay and generates the HTML markup for
displaying it okay he says you could
learn all of the attributes to set for
it but usually people resort to using
the designer and Visual Studio okay yet
so I read there was a manual and Ektron
manual that came with this content
management system and I looked through
it and a lot of the stuff was saying
like use the designer in visual studio
well I don't I don't have visual studio
I've never used it before and I'm I'm
just like looking at this like can I
just edit the code so I don't know but
to me I feel more comfortable just
looking at the code instead of trying to
learn a different you know editor kind
of more like a visual editor hopefully I
can do everything that I need to do
without having to do that so it's my
understanding that vision that Visual
Studio for Mac is not the same as Visual
Studio for Windows so it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be a simple thing for me to get
that I'd have to either run Windows like
as a second operating system on my Mac
or get a better Windows I ever really
old Windows laptop for testing and I
don't want to run anything on that
because it's too slow but it's so far
I've been able to do everything in the
code that I wanted to do
world boss says is dotnet better than
JavaScript so far just from my
experience I prefer JavaScript but I
have very limited experience with dotnet
so I guess just take that a
consideration when when you hear my
opinion on that that I'm probably not
the best person to ask I did I haven't I
haven't had a fun time whenever I've had
to work with dotnet the few times that
I've had to work with it
I enjoy JavaScript a lot better probably
because I know it a lot better Nicholas
says okay project three day twos yep
that's it so yeah the the p.3d to
project three day two so I just decided
to shorten it like that because
otherwise it adds way too much length to
the titles so hopefully it's not too
confusing
okay let's see so we have somebody new
saying hi say nice to meet you but it's
in some other characters so I don't
really know how to say that so I'm gonna
try to translate that
alright so sorry if this is wrong if
this is not really your name I use
Google Translate to try to figure this
out so is it Clark John Peel so
hopefully that's your name once again
really sorry for messing it up but so
Park Joe until says hi nice to meet you
says I'm so I think they say they're new
here so but welcome thank you so much so
much for joining us and for saying hi
and the latch at
okay John John Hanson was saying I
should have should add height so when we
were trying to find this so I'm not
gonna go back and mess with it now but
all I'm afterwards I'll try to get this
to display so we can see what's going on
there
okay so Umberto is talking about me
posting this stuff on a repo so that he
can port it over to MVC so I'm I'm
interested in that but I'm just
wondering like is that I don't know
enough about this to even though what's
what's entailed in this but would that
work within the system I mean would it
be would it work within the Ektron
system or would this be something
entirely different that would replace it
so I'm not sure but I will I'll try to
get you the I'll try to make a repo that
I can have public the only thing I'm
worried about is there's a config file
that has like usernames and passwords
for the database so I want to make sure
that there's no more config files with
information like that you know hiding
somewhere so I just need to figure it
out for sure and then get everything
together and then I'll make a Omega repo
so I don't know how soon I'll be able to
do that but I'll try to get it done you
know maybe in the next week or two
okay
okay Raphael says to work with asp.net
webforms you need Windows Plus Visual
Studio okay so there probably is some
stuff that I can't do or I won't be able
to do then alright so hopefully for what
I need to do I'll be alright but I don't
know I guess that that's kind of good
rationale for me maybe getting a new
computer here at work so that would be
kind of cool I mean I'm still gonna
mainly develop on my Mac because I'm
used to that I like it but it might not
be a bad idea to have a good Windows
machine as well we'll see if I ask they
probably just tell me to have the new
web developer and the IT department
handle everything because they're
getting the new the new web developer
gets a new Windows PC and the Mac
okay
all right I've gotten to the bottom of
the live chat so I'm gonna wrap this up
I I wanted to say something now I'm
forgetting oh oh I want to say this
especially if anybody's watching
actually our viewers have kind of
dropped off at the end there which is
kind of normal but I know there are some
people that watch the show that are also
in the react nanodegree program so
here's a little bit of of information
that was helpful to me you all maybe
already know this maybe I just didn't
read properly but I was really worried
that my my second project the Redux
project was due Friday so I've been
working on it a lot lately trying to get
it ready to turn in on Friday thinking
that you know it's due I'm gonna like
I'm I'm not gonna be able to finish the
course if I don't do it well I stayed up
last night until 4 o'clock in the
morning working on it so from 10 from 10
p.m. to 4 a.m. I'm working on it and
then I'm going through the list of
requirements and I'm thinking you know
what there's there's still I'm not gonna
finish this tonight there's too much
left so I said I'm gonna look up if I
can get an extension so I go read the
course handbook and it turns out that
the deadlines to submit the projects are
actually just suggested deadlines to
keep you on track the real deadline is
the complete end of a nano degree
program which I think for for my start
time the end for me is at the beginning
of November so really I have till the
beginning of November to turn this thing
in and I stayed up almost all night I
only got three hours of sleep
pretty much for no reason it was okay I
mean it was really nice to get like six
enter uninterrupted hours to just work
on it and I feel way more comfortable
with Redux now that I have
and I did almost completely finish the
project so the UI is just completely a
mess it looks like something out of the
90s webpage
I might actually leave it like that
because I think it cool it's cool when
it reminds me of the first websites I
ever built but anyway I say that because
I looked in the slack channel for the
nanodegree and there were other people
that had similar questions and weren't
sure about it so I I gave them the link
to the the place where I found that
information so I'm just I'm thinking
it's possible that there might be
somebody watching this that that might
might not know like I did so don't freak
out you don't have to turn things in you
know on the on the due date
it's just suggested so but I do really
want to get the project finished soon
and move on because the next project is
going to be react native and I've never
done anything with react native but I'm
really excited about it
I just I don't know I think that's
really cool it'll be awesome
for me to have something on my phone an
app that I made I don't know that just
seems really exciting to me
websites are cool too but like I've been
doing websites for a long time so that's
just it's lost some of the excitement
like just the the wow factor of doing it
the novelty has worn off but anyway so
I'm sorry to go on about that I just
wanted to try to be helpful okay Ally
asked what is the react nanodegree okay
so it's um okay alice has found it okay
yeah it's says founded it's pretty
expensive yes it's it's it was expensive
it was sometimes they have deals and you
can get it for cheaper but when I got it
there wasn't any like deal or anything
there was no discount
so it was $500 which when I think about
it now I'm like why did I spend $500 on
that I wish I had $500 now
but at the time I had recently completed
a project and I just got a big check
from a client so I was spending like I
was rich and so it didn't bother me and
but I think it's it's been really useful
so far so I think it will end up being
worth it I'll probably be a while before
I do another nanodegree because it is a
lot of work and money but this was been
really useful so far I think I'm gonna
do maybe a review like video after I'm
all done with it and just kind of go
over like what I thought and what I
learned and maybe that'll help other
people decide whether or not they
actually want to pay you know the $500
to do it as well okay I just see Ali
said would you say it was worth it yet
so far like I said it would be nice to
have have five hundred dollars right now
but that I paid for that but so far it's
been worth it and I'm I'm not even
through the the core [ __ ] so I've
learned a lot and I've been able to use
what I've learned in my projects for
work and it's helped me a lot for those
projects so like I learned about react
router in the nanodegree program and I
immediately started using react router
on my projects so that was that was very
useful and I think I'll probably end up
using Redux and one of my upcoming react
projects so that'll be useful as well
and I'm not really sure what kind of app
I'll build but I'm sure I'll figure
something out to try to use react native
I don't want to lose what I'm learning
so I really want to try to implement the
stuff that I'm learning in real projects
and just keep using it otherwise if I
wait a couple months I'll probably
forget a lot of what I've learned and
and then it would be more of a waste and
it wouldn't be the fault of the people
who made an Anna
would be my own fault yes races you can
learn all those things from a book as
well and faster yeah yeah you can
there's definitely a difference the one
difference that I've noticed from the
nanodegree program that you don't get in
a book is the code reviews so there's
live help so I can just ask questions
and have people look at my code just
live and help me with parts of it and
then when my project is you know at a
complete point where I think it's
finished I turn it in and then people
review my code and offer suggestions
like line by line suggestions for how I
could improve it and that's where I
think the benefit is because you're
right the actual information I mean you
can get that wherever you can just read
the docs and I actually did I ended up
reading through a lot of the redux
documentation and then I really
understood it a lot better I mean the
course was nice too but you get I got a
lot out of the docs as well so yeah and
I guess actually I don't ever really use
books so when I you can't get it from
books but I just get it from websites
like what why buy a book when you have
more up-to-date information online for
free you know not to say like I'm sure
there are really good books out there as
well I just prefer reading it or
watching a video but anyway also like
the motivation of having deadlines is
nice of having these projects and like
clear goals is really nice you know if
you're really self-motivated you don't
really you don't need that but I'm
really busy between my full-time job and
my
clients on the side and my four kids and
my wife I need some like goals and some
pressure to force myself to learn things
you know on my own time and outside of
work so that's good for me
in terms of making sure that I do it
because I I don't want to I don't want
to not finish a class that I paid $500
for so there's definitely pressure to
make it worthwhile but I wouldn't have
if it was just me I would probably just
put it off and you know so there's
definitely benefits to doing it but it
definitely depends on your learning
style and your own motivation the one
thing too about so Shave mentioned you
can go faster the one thing too is I
mean this react nanodegree it's not like
a normal like a typical classroom
setting so you do go at your own pace so
in terms of speed you're totally in
control of how fast you go through the
lessons and how fast you build the
projects but in a traditional classroom
I do agree that it's it's definitely way
slower than you could do if you're
learning on your on your own for most
people well Ali said books are also out
of date as soon as they are published I
would think that the course gets updated
the course actually has been updated a
lot since I started which is surprising
so so that's cool I mean that's it's
actually it's good and bad for me cuz
I'm in like the very first class that
started so the first day it came out I
started so we're I'm going through and
as people find bugs they get fixed but
I'm already passed those lessons so
sometimes I see where they'll say they
fixed all this stuff and I'm like whoa I
already I already figured it out you
know there's some things that were just
a little buggy at first and you just had
to kind of work around it so but they
they progressively keep getting better
as more people go through the course so
that's really cool
okay oh sure a says what about like
stackoverflow ready yeah i like to learn
from stackoverflow I don't really go on
reddit often and then you know there's
other good online resources so there's a
lot of great YouTube channels and then
right obviously free code camp is great
and there's um just looking at code
reading the documentation for the things
that I'm using is is really helpful
looking at other people's code on github
and there are some good like online
books like the the you don't know Jas
series is great and it's all available
for free on github so I think there's
there's a lot of there's a lot of great
free resources out there but for me at
least at this point in my life with
everything I have going on this is
probably the fastest way that I was
going to learn more about react and
redux and react native it worked for me
in the past when I had let's say more
time and less money that wouldn't have
been the right choice for me but for
right now I mean I'm not saying I have a
lot of money but at the time I happened
to be able to spare that money so and
still be able to pay my bills so alright
so let me okay I have another there's
another question sure I asked hey are
you interested in Android programming
I've been into that lately but I've also
been interested in react native I'm not
interested in directly programming
Android so I'm very interested in react
native but I'm not I'm not interested in
learning how to do you know for instance
like to do Java or Kotlin for Android or
Swift for iOS I think iOS is still Swift
I'm not as interested in that I'd rather
I only have so much time to learn
just focus on JavaScript and try to get
as good as I can with that then to know
like a little bit about a lot of
different languages that makes sense for
me in my career right now
I'm not opposed to switching I'm not
against other languages it just so
happens that I've already come so far
with JavaScript that it I think it would
just be better for me at this point just
to keep going with it
smilers asked that you have ite
education not formal so I mean I took I
took a programming class a C++
programming class in college but other
than that I don't have any formal
education and this has all been kind of
self-taught through almost exclusively
free online resources with the exception
of this nano degree program and maybe
like one course I bought from udemy that
was I think it was on sale for like 10
bucks so other than that though it's
it's been all free resources and just
kind of learning as I picked up clients
and learning what I need to do to
complete their projects okay
Oh James sorry I missed your question
earlier I saw it then I forgot about it
so James asks about tablets for coding
so saying can i code with a tablet if so
what would you suggest you guys see like
for instance the surface pro 3 I don't
have experience with that so I don't
know that I could be that helpful for
you I know there there are some tablets
that come with a keyboard
I would think ideally like you would
want that right or I just can't imagine
trying to to do a lot of programming on
a tablet without a dedicated keyboard
maybe even a mouse so if I were looking
for a tablet that I could code on
probably the biggest things for me would
be like is it powerful enough obviously
you're gonna probably want to use some
sort of like cloud development
that'll run in the browser so but you
just I would just kind of want to make
sure that it's powerful enough to run
that and not be too slow and then that
it's I could easily hook up a keyboard
and mouse but other than that I don't
have any like hands-on experience you
know with using a tablet of to code okay
I think I've gotten through all the
questions now okay all right so I've
been through other questions now and
that's good because I'm gonna have to
leave soon
for my my den I have a dentist
appointment today so I have to leave
soon to go see my dentist and all right
so awesome so this will end up being a
longer video than I anticipated but we
did some good work we got some we got a
lot done it may not seem like that much
to look at it actually looks worse than
when we started but behind the scenes we
worked through a lot of errors got a lot
done I'm really excited about this I
feel like I'm I'm finally starting to
wrap my head around what's going on here
and this is good I think we'll be able
to do a lot to make this homepage you
know a lot faster and just a much better
UI and so I'm excited I'm really excited
about this this would be cool at least
for me a lot of people will notice this
change this would be a big change so
that'll be fun to see what would people
around here at the university think
about it
so probably be back tomorrow around 2:00
p.m. Eastern time I'll let you know for
sure what time on Twitter so you can
follow me on Twitter if you like or if
you subscribe to this channel you should
get an alert at some point when I
scheduled the livestream so you know
either one of those two so you know one
of those two avenues will
we'll get you the time of the stream and
yeah thank you so much for watching
thank you for helping out in the live
chat a lot a lot of good advice and good
help and especially thanks to Umberto
offered a lot of help and was very
patient with me really not knowing what
I was doing so I appreciate that that
was awesome that you were very patient
and kind about telling me when I when I
was doing something wrong so again thank
you and have a great day I'll see
everyone tomorrow